okay
thank you
[Music]
i'm sorry
thank you
boys
uh oh
please
okay
um
oh well for us oh excellent
it's my first time in the building yeah
thank you
i mean it's embarrassing did you watch
the game last night that's uh
silly game eight nine nine
i watched the second period
six
hey
okay
what's the positions today boss uh you
were middle yesterday
uh
then you should know if you have one of
the seats in here
a lot of receipts don't provide
so
[Music]
okay
hey
best president ever right here zeke
oh yeah
two minute warning on the press briefing
two minute warning on the press briefing
thank you
pressure
hi everyone hello
we have another great guest today
joining us today is secretary our new
secretary of housing and urban
development marcia fudge
who was confirmed just last week we
wasted no time as you all know secretary
fudge served as u.s representative for
the 11th congressional district of ohio
for more than
12 years she's a former chair of the
congressional black caucus and earned a
reputation of tackling
the unique challenges of our district by
working across political ideologies
in 1999 secretary fudge was the last
elected the first female
and first african-american mayor of
warrensville heights ohio a position she
held for two
terms as mayor of warrensville heights
she adopted one of the first vacant and
abandoned property ordinances in the
state
additionally she brought new residential
development to the city and addressed
the city's growing foreclosure crisis
through the formation of a long
partnership that helped residents
maintain the financial security needed
to buy
or keep a home as secretary fudge has
said her first priority as secretary of
housing and urban development is to
alleviate the housing crisis
and get people the support they need to
come back from the edge
she's happy to take a couple of
questions after she gives some remarks
thank you again for coming
thank you very much jen good afternoon
good afternoon oh thank you thank you
i was wondering if i was in this room by
myself uh
jen thanks for inviting me to uh to
speak about the importance of the
american rescue plan as it relates to
the urgent needs
housing needs facing our nation today
what a way to complete my very first
week as secretary of housing and urban
development
at hud we know firsthand the severe
impact of covet 19 on our nation's
housing crisis
hud staff in every region of the country
have worked tirelessly
to assist grantees and recipients of hud
assistance in their response to the
pandemic
we've helped nurse hope we've helped
housing owners
housing authorities and communities
provide additional rental assistance
and support new efforts to eradicate
homelessness
we've extended the federal housing
administration's foreclosure and
eviction moratoriums
until june 30 to support the immediate
and ongoing needs of homeowners
under the biden-harris administration
hud is making greater efforts to keep
americans safe
from covet 19. we're strengthening
partnerships between recipients of hud
assistance
and public health agencies and health
care providers
many of the people living and living in
federally assisted housing
have risk factors that make them
particularly vulnerable to covalent
these factors include disability race
and low income
along with racial and ethnic disparities
in access to response care and
treatment we're making sure that federal
state and local efforts to reach those
most at risk of covet
are linking those efforts to people
living in housing hud supports
the american rescue plan is critical to
our success in these efforts
some of you may know that my last vote
as a member of congress was for
the american rescue plan i was proud to
vote for this historic legislation
to get help to the american people
during this moment of great challenge
i thank president biden for the
leadership that has gotten us to this
point
the american people can be confident
that help is here
the president has described the american
rescue plan as shots in arms
and money in pockets i would add it
relates to housing
the american rescue plan keeps people
housed and brings people home
and with that i would take any questions
that you would
that jen is going to allow me to take so
y'all make up any time
jen is in charge i'm just here go ahead
if i can't secretary fudge thank you for
being here we appreciate your time today
the
head of the national housing conference
said that hud's ranks have been gutted
morale has never been lower the
challenges to hud's constituents
have never been higher just in simple
terms can you destroy
describe the state of your department as
you take it over today
well i would say this to you and i
actually had the opportunity
to talk to the president about it since
i've been here we are
thousands of people short of where we
ought to be
uh our staff is outstanding
they are under resourced understaffed
and overworked
but we are going to make some major
changes and very quickly the rescue plan
is allowing us
to do things that we may not have been
able to do without it so i am especially
pleased that the president had the
foresight and the vision
to give us a historic maybe one time
opportunity to change what is going on
in housing in this country
you put out some new numbers today as
they relate to homelessness in this
country right now obviously it's a
number that the
whole country is dissatisfied by i think
the numbers should be much lower
um i'll ask this in two different ways
one can you set a goal where you think
that number should be and then what time
frame you think you can meet such a goal
to
reduce homelessness in country in this
country and specifically
for some of the blue parts of the
country that some
republicans have criticized san
francisco new york where the homeless
numbers
have been high what specific advice and
what you can specif
specifically do to target those
communities to alleviate those
those high numbers well the first thing
i say is that the president gave us a
charge early on as to what he wanted us
to focus on
especially in the first 100 days
homelessness was at the top of the list
one was expanding vouchers thirdly he
wanted us to find ways to
expand and put in the market new
affordable housing so with the forty
billion dollars that has come that we
have now
what we expect is this we have five
billion dollars set aside to do nothing
but
address homeless issues so we know that
with those resources
over the next probably 12 to 18 months
we know for a fact that we can get as
many as 130 000 people off the streets
we also know that our local partners are
going to assist us in finding
other rental uh opportunities so we
believe we can put a major dent in it
but if nothing else what we will let
them know is that there is an
opportunity to find a way off the
streets
we are we we have more programs in place
to assist people who are already in
public housing
to find a way to buy housing we know
that affordable housing is a problem all
across this country
i don't know where my republican
colleagues live that don't think that it
that there is a problem but there is
so many of us just choose to ignore it
thank you for being here uh the federal
moratorium on evictions is set to expire
at the end of this month are there plans
to extend that
and if not what do you say to families
who are worried that they may be facing
well what i would say first is that the
hud moratorium expires on june 30th
uh the cdc is in the process of trying
to determine what is the appropriate way
forward
and i would hope that you'd ask them
that question and just
one more if i can um the uh experts tell
us
that the december challenge of coded
relief is just now starting to come
online
people that we've talked to are still
seeing some big glitches you know when
they try to apply
are you confident that states and
localities now have the systems in place
to get this
as well as the next round of funding i'm
very confident i've talked with uh
secretary ellen
the treasury department is is up to the
task i mean certainly it is a different
treasury department so i'm very
confident that if they say that they can
get it out in a certain period of time
they will
our job at hud is just to give the kind
of guidance and assistance
once those funds are received thank you
secretary
excuse me um you mentioned earlier that
um
that housing prices are are increasing
also the supply of new inventory on the
market
is decreasing at the same time what can
the administration do to
get more homes on the market or bring
prices down how concerned are you about
about that dynamic
there are a couple of things that we
know can happen out of this rescue
package
one is if you look at places like a los
angeles where they have
actually purchased hotels and
motels et cetera to give people an
immediate place to go there's there are
resources
in the plan to do that the other thing
that we find is that
part of the problem with the market is
that credit is not
available and accessible to people who
actually do qualify
so since fha is certainly a part of what
what what we do
we're going to ensure that we can talk
about down payment assistance we're
going to talk about
maybe some restructuring we are going to
make sure that people who qualify have
access to credit
we all know that there have been
problems uh across this country for many
many years
that is why i'm so pleased that
president biden talks about equity
he talks about equality closing the the
racial wealth gap
which is bigger today than it was 50
years ago
so we we know that we have the tools
i think it was just a matter of making
sure that we have the will to use them
we have the
we now have the will madam secretary
thank you again
um back to the homelessness report that
you guys put out this morning the way
that test is done as you know is
you test over a few days in january of
the previous year
so that was pre-pandemic 2020. 580 000
people on the streets
pre i mean homeless pre-pandemic correct
2.2
increase from the year before do you
have any sense of how much
more homelessness may have increased
once that pandemic began say april may
end of the summer
i can't give you numbers we know that it
hasn't increased we just don't know
those numbers
so really not until next january when we
were able to get some sense of how it
was
correct and nancy and alex and then
we'll have to
let the secretary go back to work go
ahead thanks so much for being here i
appreciate it
my pleasure two questions one does the
biden administration have any plans to
restore or tweak that
obama era fair housing regulation which
the trump administration weakened in the
summer of 2020.
we are looking at it uh certainly we
know that fair housing
is in fact the law of the land and we
want to use every tool we have
i think that the prior administration
did roll back
some fair housing uh tools that we have
so we're looking at how we can
go back and make those better and get
them re-implemented
if possible and then just second
question what are your thoughts on
whether or not there's a housing bubble
right now in the u.s
well i i i would say that that's a kind
of a tricky question
um there are those who would say yes i
would say at this point that until i can
get the kind of data that i need from
the gses and from fha that's not a
that's not something that i could really
give you
an accurate answer on but i know that
there is a
problem with the market today
make it a good one alex no pressure well
i got i got two because i'm going to be
just a little bit greedy
one from our house and reporter which is
are there some parts of the
covid response whether or not an arp or
generally
that are currently temporary that you
would like to see permanent when the
crisis
eases oh i'd like to see most of it
permanent no question about it
um i think that when we talk about
housing needs we can't at this point
come up with enough money to k to take
care of all the homeless people in this
country
we cannot through this package alone
repair and restore 50 year old housing
uh authorities across this country
which are crumbling every day we cannot
abate lead in every single building we
need to
with these resources we need at least
another 70
to 100 billion dollars to do those
things so yes i'd like to see
a stream of resources available to do
this not just in this package
but ongoing and the second question is
you may have seen that
former congressman richmond weighed in
on the primary to
succeed him in his congressional seat
congressman richmond yeah i've never
heard of him
um i was wondering if you want to take
the opportunity to weigh in on your race
and
you know who you think can should
succeed you and
what you're looking for no
all right how about the senate democrats
that you run
oh absolutely
well i have two friends that are
thinking about it tim ryan of course is
thinking about it i understand dan
willey is thinking about it
i mean i think we're going to put a good
person in that race no matter who we
choose but they're both friends
i think we have a good shot at it i know
people have written off ohio
i haven't read enough ohio i believe we
can win the senate race
thank you secretary looking forward to
having you back thank you
thank you
thanks tim thank you
okay
what'd you say
we can wait till month three wait till
month three we'll be rolling it out with
people's second visits
uh as we announced yesterday i just
wanted to give you a little bit more
information on the schedule for next
week
you may have seen we confirmed that the
president will be traveling to columbus
ohio on tuesday
uh the anniversary of the affordable
care act
being signed into law the trip will be a
part of our help is here
tour and we'll highlight how the
american rescue plan will lower health
care costs for many american
families and this is a component of the
package that we've talked about but
we're still working to
ensure the american people understand
how they can benefit from this
particular piece
the affordable care act has been an
important lifeline for ohio families
for 11 years the law cut the state's
uninsured rate by
half dropping from 12 percent to 6
percent it has also provided critical
consumer protections for millions more
by preventing insurance companies
from discriminating based on
pre-existing conditions
and the american rescue plan makes
coverage under the aca
even more affordable for ohio families
over 90
000 currently uninsured ohioans can get
a better deal
on health insurance because of the law
and premiums for people who have
coverage under the aca
and the former ohio governor was one of
the first if not the first republican
governor
in the country to expand medicaid access
during that period of time and that is
something
certainly something we continue to note
around here um
another update on the schedule is uh
uh in the week uh well a couple of
updates i should say
part on the schedule and part on steps
we're taking as it relates to the
horrific events in atlanta earlier this
week
in the rake of the horrific shootings in
atlanta on tuesday the president ordered
the us flag to be flown at half-staff
as a mark of respect for the victims of
these senseless acts of violence
the president and the vice president
will also meet with representatives
from the georgia asian american and
pacific islander community when they
travel to georgia on friday
they will meet with the state
legislators and community advocates to
hear about the impact of the incident
on the community and to get their
perspective on the rise in anti-asian
uh hate incidents the president will
also also offer his support for the
aapi community in georgia and across the
country and talk about his commitment to
combating xenophobia
intolerance and hate as many of you may
know and i think we were i've been asked
about this in here previously but
senator
maisie hirono and congresswoman grace
ming have introduced legislation that
calls for
expanded doj review of covet 19 related
hate crimes
for guidance from doj to law enforcement
for best practices in reporting hate
crimes
and ensures that hate crimes information
and reporting is more accessible
to asian american communities the
president applauds this their leadership
on this issue including along with chair
judy choose and he strongly supports
these crucial aims of this legislation
he issued a presidential memorandum his
first week in office directing the
attorney general to support state and
local agencies
and aapi communities to prevent hate
crimes and expand
data collection and public reporting
that is ongoing the outreach and
engagement from doj
is already underway there's also a role
for hhs to play which we expect can
pick up more once secretary becerra
future secretary becerra is
is sworn in uh and as i noted yesterday
uh
also from here he's asked cedric
richmond uh who of course we've all
heard of and
a former congressman and susan rice to
lead an effort to engage with the
community as well
last piece today the house will also be
voting
on the american dream and promise act
and the farm workforce modernization act
president biden and this administration
support passage of both pieces of
legislation
these bills would provide a path to
citizenship for dreamers
individuals with temporary protected
status and farm workers
both pieces of legislation passed the
house last congress with bipartisan
support
and have broad support from the american
public these bills and his view and our
view are critical milestones toward much
needed relief for the millions of
individuals
who call the united states home and an
acknowledgment that a path to
citizenship for these essential workers
is critically important
to our economy and our nation's food and
agricultural sectors
we also urge congress to reform other
aspects of our immigration system
by passing president biden's build the
u.s citizenship act a
package a bill that he proposed on his
first day in office
which would establish a new system to
responsibly manage
and secure a border bring long overdue
visa reforms to keep families together
and grow our economy
and address the root causes of migration
from central america
with that zeke kick us off thank you jen
um
just follow up on a scoop from jeff over
here
um a scooplet
i don't know that reuters calls it
scooplets but you can
confirm that the u.s plans to load uh
four million astrazeneca vaccines
to mexico and canada what's the timeline
for when that investments actually take
place
and why only four million of the
stockpile that is several times
that for bacteria is an alternative
absolutely so
as i've noted here before but worth
noting again uh our first priority
remains
vaccinating the us population uh the
reality is that but the reality is the
border knows no
uh the the uh pandemic knows no
borders and ensuring our neighbors can
contain the virus is a mission critical
uh step is mission critical to ending
the pandemic we have three vaccines
approved as you well know
uh and of course uh there's a rigorous
review process by
the fda there are other vaccines of
course including astrazeneca that are
going through the approval
process now and we have been taking
action here
to get ready to get those vaccines to
the american people if they
are approved as we await fda approval
here in the u.s
many countries as you know have already
requested
uh have requested the uh have already
approved astrazeneca and also have
requested
our doses from the united states
that includes canada and mexico but is
certainly not limited to canada and
mexico
uh and balancing the need to let the
approval process play out
of the astrazeneca vaccine uh as it's
taking place in the us with the
importance of helping stop the spread
of the of in other countries we are
assessing how we can loan doses
it's not it's it's we are we're that is
our aim it's not fully finalized yet but
that is our aim and what we're working
toward
uh to canada and mexico this is a
complex process and our team is working
with the companies
uh to move it forward um and i want it
on your question about the number of
doses there have been
a range of reports about the number of
doses i can confirm that
we have seven million releasable doses
available
of astrazeneca and as noted in jeff's
scooplet which i'm just going to keep
calling it
2.5 million of those we are working to
finalize plans to lend those to mexico
and 1.5 million to canada what's the
nature of that transaction
would this be for future astrogenetic
production
meaning what's what's in the loan uh it
could be for future astrozenica
doses or other doses yes and uh
on a different topic i was wondering if
you saw the comments from uh
president vladimir putin this morning uh
responding to the president's uh
comments in the interview
on tuesday night if the president
worried at all that he may have been
inverted to start a little
more words and that uh
training shots back would not get in the
way of uh having
finding some common ground on various
shared priorities
well president put uh president biden
and president putin uh certainly have
different perspectives on
their respective countries and uh how to
approach engagement in the world
uh but where they agree is that we
should continue to work
for way look for ways to work together
as was noted and part of president
putin's comments and
there are areas of mutual interest new
start which we just extended for five
years is an example of that
obviously russia's also a member of the
p5 plus one as we look ahead to
what's possible there as it relates to
uh you know preventing iran from
acquiring a nuclear weapon
so uh we are confident that we can
continue to look for ways where there's
a
mutual interest mutual and national
interest but
the president is not going to hold back
clearly uh when he has
uh concerns uh when he has um
uh whether it is with words or actions
uh go ahead i'll go to you you have a
scooplet you can go
after a few other people go ahead on
that same topic you know
you say that you want to work together
with restaurant areas of mutual
agreement but
russia has now decided to recall its
ambassador i mean is there a concern
that the president agreeing that
russian president putin is a killer
could escalate tension even further
well our ambassador sullivan remains in
moscow
we remain uh engaged and he remains
engaged as is our team on the
ground with the russian people we
continue to believe that diplomacy is
the first
step and should always be the first step
and should be our objective
uh as we pursue all relationships even
with our adversaries uh so
um you know we are hopeful that that
will continue to be the case i just want
to get your reaction to actually
some of putin's exact words here because
he responded with a bit of a euphemism
that
translates roughly to it takes one to no
one
pointing to slavery in america treatment
of native americans the atomic bombing
of japan
does have any response to that kind of
language well the president believes
that one of the greatest
attributes of the united states is our
honest self-reflection
and our constant striving for progress
and there's always more work to do
as he's stated himself so
i can't i've been doing this long enough
not to try to get in the mind of
president putin uh but um i can assure
you that uh president biden
uh still believes there's more work we
can do here in our own country
go ahead just to follow up quickly does
you're talking about self-reflection
does president biden
regret calling vladimir putin a killer
no the president gave a direct answer to
a direct question so then how is that
how
you don't ask pay attention how is that
constructive to the relationship when
you talk about
diplomacy being primary between the u.s
and russia how is calling vladimir putin
a killer
constructive to that relationship well
president biden has known president
putin for a long time they've both been
on the global stage for a long time
worked through many iterations of a
relationship between the united states
and russia uh and he believes we can
continue to do that
does the president believe that the
leaders of
mohammed bin salman the one of the the
crown prince of
saudi arabia does he view him as a
killer i don't think i need to add more
killer names from the podium just today
i won't ask about other countries that
as well okay um but let me let me ask
you about immigration yeah
if i can quickly the president has made
it very clear in his in his recent
interview
that the border is not open effectively
this is closed except for these
unaccompanied minors right now under
humanitarian grounds for being welcomed
into the us but as we speak crews from
multiple
outlets including those from nbc news or
at the border they're seeing
many migrant families being accepted
young families being accepted into the
country
right now so can you square those two
when the message was that
families and individuals were being sent
home but unaccompanied minors
were being kept why young families are
in fact
being kept here in the u.s um and
detained well we've talked about this a
little bit in here before but
and we are still applying section 42 uh
which
uh and with the exception as of course
unaccompanied minors
uh we are uh there are a limited
scenarios
limited circumstances where we are very
limited i should say
where uh families are um uh coming
across
going through uh proper protocols at the
border uh being tested
uh and and then having their cases
adjudicated part of this is that
uh part of the reasoning is that uh of
course we've closed matamoros and some
uh there there has been some uh less
participation
in keeping some of these families in
mexico than in the past uh
in in many of these policies we have
supported but the vast majority of
people
vast vast majority who come to the
border are turned away the border is not
open
these are very limited scenarios i'm
sorry i just swallowed some mask here
okay we've all been there how limited is
very limited how many are being allowed
in as it relates to families
and specifically if the message that the
president was sending this week is that
the border was not open
what is the message to those families
given
some are being allowed in right now the
message continues to be i'd be happy to
provide you the numbers i think cbp has
the most up-to-date numbers so i'd point
you to them and they provide those
regularly we'd certainly support that
i don't have them in front of me right
now i would say the message continues to
be
now is not the time to come the vast
majority of families
of individuals are sent back are not
welcomed across the border
and that's a message we will continue to
convey clearly you talked about how the
president saw those photos in one of the
recent briefings as it relates to these
shelters
detention centers depression centers i'm
not sure what specific photos you saw
we asked yesterday we'll ask again today
can you provide those will you provide
those to
the american public to see what it looks
like there right now well first let me
say that the white house and we all in
the administration
support finding a way to grant access to
the media
to the hhs and or facilities or the
shelters where
these children are are staying for a
temporary period of time before they are
placed with family members or with
sponsored homes
the office of refugee right resettlement
is has not been hosting as you've noted
media tours of unaccompanied children
facilities
currently due to the covet 19 epidemic
pandemic but we remain committed to
transparency
and we're considering potential options
and we hope to have an update on that
soon
so even if we didn't get a tour can you
provide us the photos that the president
was provided
they there was a private briefing uh an
internal briefing
from several weeks ago uh we typically
don't provide those materials publicly
but we do
want you to be able to uh or a pool of
media uh to be able to
have your own visuals and get your own
footage of these facilities
go ahead a few things um back to russia
for a second yeah
there was the solar winds hack there was
the reported bounties on the heads of
u.s
yes the president said in this interview
something on that is coming what is the
hold up when is
when is the response from the united
states coming because he
inferred in the interviews you know stay
tuned right well we also have
already uh put forward sanctions on in
in response to the poisoning of alexi
nilvalny novalny
there's already been a release of a
report about uh their engagement in the
2020 election
and we will have responses to each of
these uh malign actions uh that we have
expressed concern about and the
president has offered a review of weeks
not months
remains still the policy uh there's of
course internal policy
decision making about to to assess and
take a look at the review but also to
make decisions about policy engagements
some of the responses may be seen some
may be unseen
and of course the president reserves the
right to respond at a manner in time of
his choosing
as any president would but he did make
clear uh that there
that the russian government will pay a
price on these
vaccines going to mexico this comes of
course as the united states is
talking to mexico about this border
situation were there any strings
attached
regarding the situation on the border
with this
decision to give seneca doses to mexico
there are several
diplomatic conversations parallel
conversations many layers of
conversations with
any every country mexico canada europe
asia around the world and certainly uh
being part of
contributing to uh preventing the spread
of a global pandemic is part of one of
our diplomatic objectives
another one of our diplomatic objectives
is working to address the challenges
uh at the border uh so it shouldn't be a
surprise that those conversations are
both ongoing and happening
i'm hearing you the vaccine was given
were their expectations set with the
mexicans that they helped deal with the
situation on the border
the there have been there have there
have been expectations set outside of
unrelated to any vaccine doses or
requests for them
that they would be partners in dealing
with the crisis on the border
uh and there have been uh requests
unrelated
that uh uh they for doses of these
vaccines
um every relationship has multiple
layers of conversations that are
happening at the same time
rule out or the united states isn't
rolling out using our vaccine stockpile
in i'm actually trying i'm actually
trying to convey that
with every country there's there's
rarely just one issue you're discussing
with any country at one time
right certainly that's not the case with
mexico it's not the case with any
country around the world
um and so uh i wouldn't read into it
more than our
ability to provide to lend vaccine doses
of a vaccine that we have some available
supply on to a neighboring country where
there is a lot of traffic that goes back
and forth between the countries
two other quick ones one relating to the
atlanta shooting uh you've been asked
this before but
in february of last year then candidate
biden said that on his first day of
office he'd send a bill to congress
repealing the liability protection for
gun manufacturers
and closing the background check
loophole i know you've been asked about
this
there's an attorney general in place now
when
if any when might we hear more
about the administration's plans
regarding gun violence it remains
a commitment a personal commitment of
the presidents to do more
on gun safety to put more measures in
place to use the power of the presidency
to work with congress
and certainly there's an important role
as you noted for the attorney general
and the justice department to play
on in this regard i unfortunately don't
have any updates for you today
but it is an issue he remains committed
to one quick local issue the house
oversight committee on monday is holding
a hearing on dc statehood
president is a supporter of this yes
does he think
it could if it passes the house
does it have a chance in the senate
given the filibuster situation right now
and what would he or the white house say
to the critics who
suggests that this is designed to be a
democratic party power grab just to get
a few more
seats in the house in the senate i think
he would say that
um the half a million people who live in
dc am i getting that number right
a little more than it's grown since i
left and went to the suburbs uh
would would argue with that point and so
would he and he believes they deserve
representation that's why he uh supports
dc statehood what
has the administration made any effort
this is just a putin relationship
has the administration made any effort
to find out what was said during the
previous president's two-hour
long one-on-one meeting with putin in
helsinki
it's a great question obviously there's
intelligence reports that may reflect
that but i'm not aware of any
specific deep dive into that i'm happy
to check if there's more on it
and just i'm sorry one more question um
the chinese government has indicated
that
it wanted it wants to meet with
president biden virtually in april
before that climate summit
i'm wondering if the biden
administration is open to that
and if there have been any talks about
setting that meeting up
i know we'll have more on the climate
summit which is just over a month away
now so it's coming closer and there are
of course a range of international
global participants that we anticipate
being a part of it but
we're not at the stage where we're
discussing bilateral meetings at this
point in time
go ahead david oh sorry jeff i really
i'll come back to you next
i'm not trying to give you a hard time
go ahead david maybe mr scooplet should
go
yeah maybe
sorry to uh go back to the russia
section here but um
the president now by my count has said
that russia would pay a price for solar
winds
he has said that they would pay a price
for navalny and as you pointed out
they've already been some sanctions
there yeah
yesterday he seemed to suggest that uh
they would pay a price uh
in addition for the meddling in the 2020
uh election and yet at the same time
your own colleagues seem to have
sanctions fatigue out here
in the government or your your
colleagues in
the in the state department the west
wing i mean you announced sanctions on
russia back when you were state
department spokesperson
uh is there any evidence that the method
that we're using
so far of sanctions is actually
affecting
putin's behavior i don't think we would
rely
david on sanctions alone we do think
they have been
effective uh modes i mean history you've
written many stories about it about the
role sanctions have played in moving
global diplomacy forward and we
certainly are a believer in that
but as you also know there are a range
of tools
at any pre the disposal of any president
seen and unseen and
i'm just not going to get ahead of the
process of what considerations are
underway
uh on china uh obviously the meeting is
yet to happen uh yeah today but
at the end of this whole process
uh once mr sullivan and mr blinken come
back
what does the president think is the
next right step
is it further meetings at this level
is it more direct conversation like the
one he had for several hours
uh last month with president xi
um is it a response to
uh the chinese related hack that
he's also trying to go deal with i
expect he'll make a determination about
that
when they return and he has a chance to
talk to secretary blinken
and national security adviser sullivan
in part because he doesn't see this nor
do they
as a preset series of meetings like
the traditional um dialogues that we've
seen
uh throughout other administrations
including ones that he has previously
served in
you know this meeting we certainly
anticipate we'll have
difficult components of the conversation
we expect it to be
frank they plan to cover areas where we
have concerns
including human rights hong kong uh
obviously we've uh we've
put forward some sanctions uh related to
uh
the anti-democratic actions in hong kong
over the last couple of days
technology whether it relates to threat
uh the theft of
ip or data protections uh
military tensions in the region so it
will cover as will be no surprise to
anyone here who
follows china closely a range of topics
and i think the president's eager to
hear from them
on how the conversation goes and work
with them to determine what the next
right step is
i will say that in his mind and in the
minds of national security advisor
sullivan and
and secretary of state um blinken a big
part of the strategy
is uh approaching our relationship with
china from
a place of strength and strengthening
our
uh own economy at home investing in the
middle class
uh looking at it through the prism of uh
competition not conflict and
that means there's also more work we
have to do here your answer things like
the economic and strategic
dialogue which took place in the obama
administration that
continued some in the in the trump
administration
that's over for now i i would simply say
that this meeting is not a part of a
series of
of meetings at this point in time go
ahead
oh sorry jeff you're kind of getting
hazed for your scooplet
right i know you can okay he'll just sit
on his scooplet he doesn't care
go ahead karen a couple questions on
schools um last month the cdc released
school guidance urging six feet of
distance between students and staff
and now the cdc director says she's
revisiting this we're reporting that
this could come as early as tomorrow
then that will go from six feet to three
feet
what does the white house say to
teachers who are concerned that the
science hasn't changed in five weeks and
that this is
political this change i would say that
the cdc is full of health and medical
experts including dr walensky who would
be the last person to characterize
herself as political
she is a medical health expert and she
has
looked at this through the prism of how
we can
take steps to make it safe to reopen
schools
and is constantly evaluating how to ease
some of the restrictions and
there are of course more that often
you've all have asked about and here
which are good questions
what about travel what about masks uh
you know they take an approach that is
purely through the science so we'll let
her
speak more about it when they're ready
to release those formal guidelines
the white house directs states to do
something with that guidance when it's
released similar to what we saw when the
president
made the direction on vaccine
eligibility
you mean like will we direct schools to
now do this the cdc has said this six to
three feet
you now have to follow this to push for
reopening well
social distancing is one of the
mitigation measures right in the cdc
guidance and i don't know i have not
seen the cdc guidance
so i don't know how it will be
characterized in there but i would
certainly say we'd have secretary
cardona
who was just here yesterday work with
schools and school districts to
implement and
social distancing is one of the steps
masking testing
vaccinations and see how it can help
reopen schools more quickly
i mean kind of overnight go from six to
three feet in the schools that are open
right now and possibly increase the
number of students that can be in the
classroom
before the end of the year i don't have
a timeline for it i don't anticipate
we'd ask any school to do something
immediately overnight
um but it will just be additional
guidance which a lot of schools are
looking for
from health and medical experts on on
how to safely reopen schools and ensure
that
uh the the parents in the community the
uh teachers in the community the
students feel safe going to school and
this just
as they're considering options this is
one of the options
uh that will that one of the mitigation
steps of school can take
uh go ahead um two quick questions
uh to continue with the scooplet theme
okay um
there was a report just about an hour
ago that
the president intends to nominate bill
nelson as nasa
chief can you confirm that i've seen
those reports
i don't have any personal announcements
to make today
it seems like a cool job though then i'm
not currently on the path too but it's
fine you're not auditioning right now i
am certainly not
i don't have any personal announcements
to make certainly seen the reports as we
have any updates we'll provide them
and the same question you know the
president said yesterday that he intends
to
try to raise taxes on anyone that was
making over 400
000 a year does he think that that's
uh does he intend to wait until
the economy is out of uh the
pandemic recession or does he feel
confident that
uh that by making it only on higher
earners that it will not affect the
broader economy
well the president is certainly focused
on ensuring the
economy is continuing to recover and
that people are
going back to work and able to put food
on the table to
feed their families when we're talking
about people families making over four
hundred thousand dollars a year
that's about two percent of households
in this country
and this is a commitment that he talked
about on the campaign trail
and his interest is in ensuring that
people
pay their fair share whether it's
corporations or the highest income
earners in our country
and uh he believes that um you know hard
work should be
rewarded and that this is one of the
areas where there could uh where there
is an opportunity to
uh rebalance uh how our policies are
currently
but i you know he would do this in
coordination with of course
members of congress members of his
economic team and we obviously don't
have a
proposed plan at this point but it is it
is a
um a policy that he talked about on the
campaign trail and he reiterated as you
noted earlier this week did you have a
second question too
or not those are the two questions this
okay okay got it okay okay go ahead jeff
all right the man of the
you mentioned that the us has seven
million
doses releasable doses and the company
itself has said
uh it expects to have up to 30 million
uh in april
given that will the us consider lending
sharing more of these doses with the
other countries that are asking
now that you've confirmed that you're
doing the same for mexico and canada
we don't have anything to preview but we
all uh have a number of requests
from a range of countries around the
world and certainly will continue those
conversations
okay but no commitment at this point to
share specifically the estrogenic
vaccine with others well i will say
broadly speaking we also
anticipate having additional doses of
moderna of pfizer of a range of vaccines
even as we focus on vaccinating ensuring
every american every adult american has
access to the vaccine
it's just a matter of timeline so i just
don't have a an update or a preview on
that but certainly we'll have those
conversations and we are
open to uh receiving those requests and
and obviously uh making considerations
all right and just on one other issue
your new u.s trade representative will
be ceremonially sworn in
later today 97 to
that's english for voting number it's
pretty solid what uh
how soon will she start leading
uh trade talks with the uk i don't have
anything to preview obviously that's
driven by the
policies and the agenda of president uh
and
the overall economic team i'm sure we'll
be integrating her into
all of the policy discussions as as soon
as she's sworn in
let me just go to get to the folks in
the back go ahead thank you ma'am a
couple quick questions
when you were talking a moment ago about
diplomatic negotiations between united
states and mexico
um you said crisis on the border is
is that a challenge is on the border
okay but so that's not that doesn't
reflect any change
in no administration's view of things
nope
okay well uh another quick question then
um on monday the president said it's
important to get the vaccine
and then quote even after that until
everyone is in
vaccinated to wear this mask unquote
was he speaking generally or does he
believe that we should all be wearing
masks
until everyone is in fact vaccinated
well i think what he's reflecting is the
guidance from our health experts that
even if you're vaccinated i am
vaccinated i still wear a mask
because there hasn't been conclusive
studies yet
on the transferability of the the
uh pandemic or covid uh for from those
who have been vaccinated he's
and he it continues to be the advice of
health and medical experts to continue
to wear masks
every american is that the standard
until everyone american has been
vaccinated or was he speaking generally
i think he's speaking generally about
the need to still observe
measures like social distancing and
wearing of masks
so that even when you're vaccinated
you're keeping your neighbors your
friends
your family members safe and then back
in january
you noted that the administration was
reviewing how unmarried couples were
handled under travel restrictions um
have there been any developments on
those restrictions
um i know that there's a lot on the
administration's play yeah but in how
um unmarried uh binational couples
are are treated i don't have any update
for you the review is ongoing
one more question sure thank you you're
very generous um
the equality act as it's currently
written would eliminate the religious
freedom restoration act
uh as a defense for religious
organizations against discrimination
claims given that president biden vote
in favor
of rifra uh does he support it being
abolished now
i would have to check on the specific
components of the package i'm happy to
i'm happy to do that for you after the
briefing go ahead in the back
thank you very much jen um two east asia
questions and one uh asian american
question okay
u.s china talks can we expect the uh
joint statement of the talks
a joint statement uh between them i i
don't have anything to preview i know
that um
national security adviser sullivan and
secretary blinken will be
speaking briefly after the talks
conclude but i don't have anything to
preview for you in terms of a joint
statement
okay another question is according to
japanese media
japanese prime minister asuga will meet
president biden on april 9.
uh can you confirm that uh i know there
have been reports
about a future meeting and the
president's certainly looking forward to
meeting with the prime minister of japan
uh i don't believe a final confirmation
has been made
here of what that meeting will look like
and what the format would be
okay one asian-american question okay on
the unfortunate
atlanta shooting we already see the half
staff
outside um yesterday you blamed the
prior administration about this which
some people agree but as what
uh actuals reports quote
the united states rivalry with china had
already created on east about
chinese americans and asian americans
unquote and actually said we are going
to see
a huge jump in hate crimes against
asian americans this year so it seems to
be
that president biden is in this catch
22. um on the one hand he is trying to
alleviate
uh the hate crimes against asians and
asian americans
on the other hand he's kind of escalates
the tension
how can he uh really alleviate
this situation i would just refute the
notion of that question
i would say that yesterday i was asked
which was a good question
if we thought that the former
president's rhetoric
had contributed to the
actions or the um the discrimination
against asian americans and i said we do
because
rhetoric certainly from the the um
the massive megaphone you have from the
white house is something that is heard
across the country and
it's important to then be thoughtful
about the words you use and how you
convey
uh opposition to discrimination of any
kind uh that was the answer the question
i was answering
uh the president is and the vice
president are meeting with leaders of
the asian american community tomorrow
uh they the president raised the
rhetoric his concerns about
rhetoric about attacks about threats
against the asian american community in
the country
during his prime time address he signs
an executive order
he's asked his members of administration
to
listen hear think about policy solutions
i would say he's his effort is to be
part of the solution not part of the
problem
uh so i would uh just dispute your uh
your question
go ahead in the back thanks jeff a few
questions for you
the president mentioned in his abc
interview uh
his thoughts on potential changes to the
filibuster uh does he support getting
rid of the 60 vote threshold
on the legislative filibuster i think
what he said
is that he'd be open to hearing ideas
about going back to the talking
filibuster which
mr smith goes to washington is the best
reference that
anyone can make on that front obviously
that hasn't been uh the law in the
senate for
since before i was born uh so many years
but he
that is a that is a proposal that had
been put forward by senator manchin
and his whole point is that and as he
said in his
uh comments you know our democracy looks
at moments like it's broken
and uh it shouldn't be so easy to block
legislation
at the same time his preference and his
priority
is working with democrats and
republicans to find a pathway forward on
a range of issues where there has been a
history of bipartisan support whether
it's
infrastructure immigration addressing
making our economy and our workers more
competitive against
uh against the competition with china
there are a lot of ways we can work
together that's his preference and so he
was just expressing an openness to
hearing from members of the senate on
what their ideas are
ultimately though as president he
doesn't get it he doesn't vote here it's
not a law he signs into law it's a
senate rule
so uh you'll have to talk to them about
uh what their ideas are and what they
have the votes for
to move forward so he would defer to
senators on whether they would support
scratch it's not about deferring he's
not in the senate he doesn't decide what
the senate roles are they do
influence if he were to voice an opinion
he's going to have the
the senators decide uh what uh what
rules they want to abide by moving
forward
quick ones um i wonder there are a few
key agencies that have yet to have
uh senate nominated or confirmed leaders
that are um certainly in the news now
uh cbp ice um the fda
during the pandemic i wonder if does the
administration have any plans for a
timetable for when it might
uh put forward nominees to lead those
agencies
all important agencies i don't have any
update on the personnel process but
we're working our way through and
ensuring we have the right people
we can nominate for each of those
important roles and then lastly um i
wonder
uh this week there's a group of college
basketball players ahead of the ncaa
tournament
who started a protest on social media
with the hashtag not ncaa
property they're looking for more
financial freedom
and personal protections from the ncaa i
wonder um
one of the things they're asking for is
a meeting with federal officials and
potentially the vitamin administration
to talk about legislation on this
so does the president support uh college
athletes being able to profit off their
name and likeness
and would the administration be willing
to meet with these players if they ask
for a meeting
i'm happy to see if there's any plans
for a meeting and if we've received the
request
go in the back thank you jen um
questions from u.s china meeting
um china has a poor record of keeping
promises so how would you characterize
the level of trust that the current
administration has with regard to china
and also for the for the um
for the bilateral meeting between
president biden and
president xi um what are the conditions
that has to happen what are the
conditions for the meeting to happen
thank you i don't think i'm here to set
conditions today there we haven't even
announced the specific details about
the um climate summit that's happening
in april which i think
was what the bilateral question was
around
and we certainly haven't made a final
decision about any bilateral meetings
around that meeting as we do i'm sure we
can discuss it further
uh and then as it relates uh to the
meeting uh today
i i think one uh that starts today i
should say
um it was important to our
administration that the first meeting
with chinese officials be held on
american soil
and occur after we have met and
consulted closely with partners and
allies in both asia and europe
this is an opportunity to address a wide
variety of issues including ones where
we have deep disagreements and so
our focus is on having a frank
discussion raising issues where we have
concerns and
of course looking for ways and places
where we can work together
go ahead while you've been briefing
president putin has just extended an
invitation to president biden to
continue their conversation
but this time he wants to do it live
he's asking for a live streamed
conversation an open direct dialogue
putin says he's available tomorrow or
monday
is this something that you would
consider uh i'll have to
get back to you if that is something we
are entertaining uh i would say that the
president uh
already had um a conversation already
with president putin even if
as there are more world leaders that he
has not yet engaged with and we engage
with
russian uh leaders members of the
government at all levels
but i don't have anything to report to
you in terms of a future meeting the
president will of course be in georgia
tomorrow and quite busy go ahead one
very quick final question on the wall on
day one in office i think it was the
president signed a proclamation that was
eventually putting a pause or halting
wall construction
um at the time i think he directed
federal agencies to formulate a plan
within
60 days depending who's counting we're
on 58 59 or
two more days do we have okay some said
two tonight i thought it was one but
we'll go with two more days
to redirect order fund border wall funds
and quote resume modify or terminate
segments of the structure that remain
under construction
have those federal agencies provided you
with their conclusions have you come to
a conclusion
what is the status of that with that
remaining one or two days left
i will check and see if there's an
update um we
are of course there is funding that was
appropriated previously that is still
moving forward um
money that has not been appropriated as
you noted we've kind of pulled back on
uh but i will check and see we have two
more days which is a lifetime in this
place uh
and see if we have an update for you on
this step yes thank you thank you thank
you everyone
it's okay oh it's your first day i'm
sorry
welcome so a lot of my colleagues uh in
this room outside this room have been
asking for a while now about the
possibility of visiting
these facilities where unaccompanied
children are being held after
arriving and applying for asylum at the
border and part of the pushback that
we've received from you and from dhs and
hhs
uh is that their privacy concerns um
about reporters potentially you know
and covet and privacy concerns but
specifically to privacy
reporters have been allowed inside these
facilities for years through
multiple administrations by multiple
agencies including by the last
administration
during the family separation crisis
where i think the
risk of like further emotional damage
these kids is pretty acute
so has there been to your knowledge any
instant
incident in which a kid's privacy was
violated by reporters who were there to
cover the facilities in which they're
being detained
during the last administration the long
history of reporters
i would say as i noted in response to a
question or two questions that were
asked earlier that were very similar
our big concern has been the pandemic
and covid and safety of course there are
privacy concerns that
anyone takes into account or i would say
any administration should take into
account
as it relates to members of the media
visiting a facility where there are
children
as i'm as i'm sure you would certainly
agree on i can't speak to what the
approach was of the prior administration
who was ripping children from the arms
of their parents so
i can't speak to what their policies
were but we are working and we're very
committed here from the white house and
from the
government in finding a way soon very
soon
uh to ensure that there is access by the
media uh
not by not by us providing you with what
we see but by the media to
these shelter facilities uh we believe
it's it's important and vital and
we're committed to it and we're just
working through the pandemic is about
the safety of staff the safety of kids
as well and that's uh that's what we're
working through at this point in time so
hopefully i'll have an update soon
thanks everyone
okay social distancing speaking out yeah
um the
president said uh in the interview when
he was discussing uh going back to
you know talking filibuster uh that the
filibusters went on its mind because
we're almost getting to a point where
democracy is having a hard time
functioning but
my colleague points out that that
dynamic has been true specifically in
the senate for
a very long time years even um so was
there anything specific to the current
dynamic in the senate
uh that made president guidance sort of
decide that
you know now is a moment to change the
filibuster sure well as i answered in
response to the question just a few
minutes ago
uh there are a number of ideas that
members of the senate have put forward
uh they're they range some are against
changing the filibuster in the
democratic party some are for it some
are for going back to a talking
filibuster back to the days of
mr smith goes to washington he's he's
watching it closely he was in the senate
for 36 years he's happy to hear their
ideas
his preference remains working with
democrats and republicans to get
business done for the american people so
it's a conversation as you well know
that's happening on capitol hill
right now and he's certainly watching it
as most other people are as well
thank you everyone
you